-Oh, my goodness,
the one and only!
Now, Lin...
-Aah, aah!
-...here's how this works.
I'm gonna hit this button here
and activate
a random word generator.
It lands on three words.
It's your job to work them all
into a freestyle rap.
Now, because I'm not really
known for my freestyle skills,
you'll be facing off against --
-That's not what I've heard.
-[ Laughs ] Trust me.
You'll be facing off The Roots'
own Black Thought right there.
Ladies and gentlemen.
Here we go.
-The greatest of all time,
the greatest of all time.
-All right, you ready for this?
-No! Let's go.
-Here we go.
[ Musical beeping ]
-No whammies, no whammies,
no whammies, no whammies.
-Flip flops, seared salmon --
these are easy ones --
prescription sunglasses.
-Great.
-All right, so you have to
work this in --
flip flops, seared salmon,
and prescription sunglasses.
He's not heard these words
before.
-Okay.
Roots, can you give him a beat?
Let's see how he...
[ Hip-hop music plays ]
♪♪
-♪ Yo, en Español, Ingles,
from "A" to zeta ♪
♪ Your grandmother would hit you
with the el chancleta ♪
♪ Oh, it hits me in the head
till my hip hops ♪
♪ But I got smacked in the back
with some flip flops ♪
♪ Oh, yeah,
you know that I be jammin' ♪
♪ You know I keep it smooth
like I got that seared salmon ♪
♪ Or is it smoked? ♪
♪ I don't really know ♪
♪ I'm just freestylin'
on "The Tonight Show" ♪
♪ But I guarantee I knock 'em
on they asses ♪
♪ I hit you with
the BluBlockers ♪
♪ Prescription sunglasses ♪
[ Ding! ]
-BluBlockers!
Bonus points!
Bonus points for BluBlockers!
-BluBlockers.
-Oh, my gosh!
-Thank you.
-Oh!
Tough to top.
Tariq, you are up, my friend.
Here we go.
-Okay.
[ Musical beeping ]
-No whammies.
-It'll be easy for you.
Loofah, Daenerys Targaryen.
[ Laughter ]
Look at that, the reaction.
Daenerys Targaryen.
-Rastafarian.
[ Laughter ]
-Goodnight!
[ Ding! ]
♪♪
-That's your whole freestyle?
Ugh, now you can't use that.
Okay, you got loofah,
Netflix password,
and Daenerys Targaryen.
Roots, can you give him a beat?
Go for it, bud.
[ Hip-hop music plays ]
♪♪
-♪ Hey, yo ♪
♪ I'm still the answer,
Mansa Musa ♪
♪ I'm just absorbin' it all in,
loofah ♪
♪ Still I never let a scrub
get the last word ♪
♪ On my watch
like a Netflix password ♪
♪ As far as the bar is just
rigorous ♪
♪ Makin' other rappers run like
faras ♪
♪ Till y'all learn
who the realest barbarian ♪
♪ I burn all y'all,
Daenerys Targaryen ♪
[ Ding! ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Laughs ]
-What?!
-You did not take
the easy way out.
That was --
That's unbelievable, man.
-Whoo!
Delicious!
-Soaking it all in.
Soaking it all up
like a loofah.
Thank you, Tariq.
We have time for one more,
I just heard from the booth.
Lin, you're up.
Let's see what words you get.
[ Musical beeping ]
-Oh.
[ Beeping slowly ]
-Waffle fries, Pikachu,
and Puerto Rico.
-Oh, all righty.
-Waffle fries, Pikachu.
These are random words.
-This is interesting.
-[Bleep]
-Roots, go ahead.
Give him the beat.
[ Hip-hop music plays ]
♪♪
-♪ My mind is open
like a lighthouse ♪
♪ Pretty scared about what's
goin' on in the White House ♪
♪ Look around, those look like
some awful guys ♪
♪ I want to hit 'em with
some chancletas ♪
♪ And some waffle fries ♪
♪ Aw, yeah, too many plans,
I can't hatch 'em all ♪
♪ But it's like Pikachu,
I got to catch 'em all ♪
♪ What the "F" is goin' on? ♪
♪ I'm rockin' to the break of
dawn with my Pokémon ♪
♪ Oh, but all things
bein' equal ♪
♪ This is the freestyle sequel
from here to Puerto Rico ♪
[ Ding! ]
♪ Oh, yeah ♪
♪ They're pickin' up
what I caught ♪
♪ Now let's hear it for
Mr. Black Thought ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Just hand it to me, please.
Mic is too expensive to drop.
The mic's too expensive to drop.
Thank you so much
for doing that.
Lin, you've proven yourself
an amazing rapper,
and you actually have an
exciting freestyle project
coming to Broadway.
-Yes, that's true, Jimmy.
Before "Hamilton,"
before "In the Heights,"
my first time performing
in New York
was with a freestyle hip-hop
group called
Freestyle Love Supreme.
We are coming to Broadway
this fall
at the Booth theatre.
-Yes!
-It's an entirely made-up
Broadway show.
You don't know
who's gonna show up.
Black Thought might show up,
I might show up one night,
Chris Jackson might show up
one night.
You don't know
what's gonna happen.
Come see us in September.
-That is major news.
Previews for
"Freestyle Love Supreme"
begin this September
at the Booth Theatre!